if you think about trying to define the
American state of capitalism's as
opposed to save the European state or
other states of capitalism it or the
Chinese capitalism let me there's a
there's a wonderful book that a Harvard
Business School professor named Deborah
spar wrote called ruling the waves which
is a history of a comparative history of
telecommunications technologies in the
u.s. the UK and on the continent of
Europe and she talks about the Telegraph
the telephone television the internet
mobile phones and and she found a
pattern I mean and that the pattern is
this on the continent of Europe a
national champion or a corporation is
created it's a it's a pay today I mean
it you know it's due to telecom is so
it's so it's a division of the state is
created that develops the technology
it's a state monopoly and then maybe
eventually 50 or 100 years later
competition comes in on the UK in the UK
a private national champion corporation
a publicly chartered corporation like
the BBC or British Telecom is created
it's not owned by the state but it's a
monopoly and it's responsible to this
and it's responsible to the state and
then a bskyb or some other competition
comes in and in the United States in
general we let a thousand flowers bloom
you have an Oklahoma land rush we have
this crazy generation of a million
different conflicting ideas then there's
a wild consolidation a lot of businesses
die and some sort of and and and and
others are formed and some sort of
consensus around standardization around
standards and and some sort of some
staple state with three or four of
competitors emerges very different
models and it's a pattern we've done
over and over and over again I mean it
may be a legacy of the frontier it may
be a legacy of just sort of you know
raise the gates partners send those kind
of Soviet out and good luck you know I
mean it could be a cultural a cultural
thing it's certainly it's a gold rush
kind of mentality certainly the dock
boom was the biggest thing in California
since the gold rush you know 150 years
before so I think that's our cultural
capitalist pattern easy to start a
company easy to go bust easy to come
back after you've done it I think in the
last few years or the the risks I mean
each of these has their own benefits you
know you know and and and you know their
own risks and rewards and God knows that
if I had lived through the first half of
the 20th century that Europe had had I
would want to have I would not consider
change my friend I would want to have a
set of regulations and government
policies that made it difficult to have
radical crazy new ideas because of the
social and military and other
catastrophes that happened on the
continent of Europe and them in the
first half of the 20th century but but I
think we're seeing some pretty risky
elements in our model - I mean obviously
there have been first of all there the
risk their personal risks of failure and
we our social safety net is smaller and
has more holes in it and people fall
through it I think there's also a risk
of and we're seeing this fiercely a risk
of real income disparity and I think we
have reached a dangerous place in the
United States now where first of all the
rewards at the top are so enormous I
mean the money made by billionaires
today makes Rockefeller look like a
piker and and so the the Diskin there's
I think a rather growing disconnection
between the rewards available to the top
and the consequences to everybody else
so we're not really we're not in the
same boat and and when the rewards are
so great it's a lot easier for me if I
have a chance at those rewards to say oh
well the hell with anybody else I'll
just you know if I can be a Centon
millionaire why should I care about my
name
this is too big an opportunity to pass
up whereas if I can only be a
millionaire
maybe I I maybe I will pay a little more
attention to to what I do to bring the
whole neighborhood up with me so I think
this is I think there's a real a real
danger in there